in this video we're going to talk about
hair nails and skin there's many
different causes to a problem with loss
of hair brittle nails or a skin that
becomes let's say extra dry or you start
losing your collagen but I'm going to
talk about the probably the most common
thing that I find and you may want to
try this okay so the first thing I want
to tell you is that the majority of
people addressing these three things are
doing it from the outside in their
choosing lotion serums creams on the
face hoping that's going to go into your
body and make the skin all real nice or
they're using different types of shampoo
that will make your hair more lustrous
and with filled with collagen hope
hopefully that collagen will sink in
there and go into the hair but that
never works of course then they have the
nails that they've fake nails right so
how do we make the nails really really
strong and hard enough and the skin
really nice and also the hair so doesn't
fall out well we want to apply the
philosophy of inside-out we want to
start building up our body from the
inside out and doing things to improve
the health but you probably are already
eating fairly decent if you're watching
my videos you're reading probably foods
with vitamins and minerals you taking
vitamins and minerals and you might
still have a problem with this and that
is because there's a certain nutrient
that's very deficient in the problem
with this and that has to do with trace
minerals now why trace minerals first of
all what is a trace mineral trace
minerals are those minerals needed in
very small tiny amounts and trace
minerals function to help make enzymes
work
what do enzymes do that's the workhorse
of the body there's like thousands of
enzymes in your body doing the work to
building up protein and breaking protein
down and that's what enzymes do in fact
enzymes without enzymes you couldn't
even grow your hair so you have a
hormone component part and then you also
have a trace mineral
component part that activates the enzyme
so you can actually build protein in the
body because if you think about it it's
not necessarily that you're not eating
enough protein you're probably eating
enough protein and you're eating
collagen in that protein because that's
what collagen is a type of protein but
it's the activation of that protein to
make it available through the liver and
up through the skin into the hair so
this is something that I've tried a lot
of people it's work
you may want to try it yourself consume
more trace minerals trace minerals are
probably the number one deficient thing
in our company in the United States now
because the soils are so depleted they
only the farmers only put three minerals
back into the soil in some cases they
don't put all the trace minerals one is
there's no real requirements that are
listed like the RDA is for trace
minerals even though we need them and
it's necessary so they help fortify our
hormones like even iodine you need
iodine it's try to find some food with
iodine unless you consume sea kelp so
trace minerals are very missing in our
environment and it's very essential in
to build protein hair nail skin now if
you go to the store or online and get
trace minerals you're probably going to
see a lot of different versions of trace
minerals and that are salt based or some
of my kool-aid colloidal minerals salt
based minerals from the sea those are
all fine but you really only absorb 5%
of those and they're a different form of
chemistry they're harder to absorb I'm
going to recommend you do plant-based
trace minerals now what is plant-based
trace minerals
they're basically plants that were grown
on soils with the trace minerals so that
way the plant pulls them up into the
plant and then you consume the plant and
now it goes right in like a rocket ship
plant-based trace minerals have their
fifteen thousand times smaller than
regular trace minerals that are from the
sea so they're very tiny they go in like
a rocket ship and they create some cool
effect and so you don't need as much so
now where can you find trace minerals if
there's really no soil left well
can go next to a volcano where they have
the soils have been fortified with the
deep parts of the earth from the
volcanic ash and they have volcanoes in
Italy and Hawaii and just move there and
live off the land you can do that and
you're going to get all the trace
minerals
that's probably why those people their
skin looks a lot better or you can get a
plant-based trace mineral from a
prehistoric time so I want to show you
the one that I have it's called trace
minerals this is basically 70 million
years old it still still works and this
was captured in a layer of the earth 70
million years ago where they had all the
prehistoric plant vegetation and they
had all the trace minerals back then and
those minerals have been protected for a
long time so there's a company that can
that capture that material and made into
a water-soluble product and that's what
I use because you just need a dropper
full or two in some water a day to help
get those plant-based trace minerals so
unfortunately we can't go back in the
time but the prehistoric minerals are a
good way to get the plant based unless
you have your own garden you can start
fortifying the soils so trace minerals
are probably the number one single thing
that you can do but there's something
else as well and that has to do with
certain types of fats now a lot of the
remedies for hair nail skin involve fat
soluble vitamins vitamin A vitamin D
vitamin E all these are really good for
the skin if you're consuming those and
it's not working there's something else
you want to look at and that has to do
with one more thing and that has to do
with this thing called bio not enough
bile from your gall bladder so if you
have a digestive issue you'll see you're
bloating and you're burping and you have
belching and all that or your stomach's
distended when you eat then you could be
deficient in bile so because bio helps
you digest fats so if you don't have
enough file you're
all blood will be stressed and bile
helps you absorb all the oils essential
fatty acids all the fat soluble vitamins
to start helping the skin it's just
another thing that I find with people
with dry skin or collagen problems so
the combination of some extra bio and
trace minerals are probably the number
one thing that I would recommend to
enhance your hair and nails and skin and
you may want to try it out hope you
enjoyed this video I'll see you in the
next one